[Musique]
gloire à qui frine à mort de peur des
crabouillé le hérisson perdu le crapau
pourvoyer et gloire à
donjan d'avoir un jour
souris à celle à qui les autres
n'attachaient aucun prix cette fille est
trop vilaine il me la
faut gloire au flic qui barrait le
passage aux autos pour laisser traverser
les chats de
lesutau
et gloire à
donjan d'avoir pris
rendez-vous avec la délaissé de l'amour
des avou cette fille est trop vilaine il
me la
faut gloire au premier venu qui passe et
qui se te quand la aille cri Arau sur le
Bodet et gloire à don
juant pour ses galants discours à celle
à qui les autres faisaient jamais la
cour cette fille est trop vilain il me
la
faut et gloire à ce curé sauvant
son
ennemi lors du massacre de la
saintbtheléie et gloire à
donjan qui couvrit de
baiser la fille que les autres
refusaient d'embrasser cette fille est
trop vilain il me la
faut gloire à ce soldat qui jeta son
fusil plutôt que d'achever l'otage à sa
merci et gloire à
donjan d'avoir osé
trousser celle dont le jupon restait
toujours baissé cette fille est trop
vilaine il me la
faut
gloire à la bonne sœur qui partant pas
très chaud déga dans sa main le pénis du
manchau et gloire à
donjan qui fit reluir un soir ce cul des
hérités ne sachant que s'assoir cette
fille est trop V
il me la
faut gloire à qui n'ayant pas l'idéal
sacrin ce borne ne pas trop
enemmerder ses
voisins et gloire à don juant qui rendit
femme celle qui sent lui que horreur
serait morte puis celle cette fille est
trop vilain il me la
[Musique]
faut